Dear farmer friends,
don't go to the wrong fight,
get informed
and take a good look at your union leaders.
Hopefully, the
French will not wait to have empty refrigerators
to stand up and walk beside us.
Please,
just take
2 minutes of your time to listen until the end.
You all know that,
in France 30% of farmers do not arrive
not to see a correct income
and 50 farms close every day
and that is precisely their objective.
Close your operations to redeem yourself.
Finally the multinationals
Americans already own 53% of the
Ukrainian agricultural land.
Tomorrow you will be simple employees of Rousseau
and his American friends.
Open your mind
to better situate yourself in this Europe.
It is not with government measures
that we can keep alive
in our operations.
The media doesn't tell you about it,
but we have the same movement of farmers
in 8 other European countries,
in Germany,
Belgium,
in Poland,
Bulgaria and Romania,
in Italy,
Spain and even Portugal.
You understand better,
the farmers' struggle is quite different.
Each country must regain its agricultural sovereignty.
We do not need new laws but rather
to leave this Europe.
We are here to defend ourselves,
we want to continue with our France,
we don't want Europe,
we don't want globalization,
not of all this.
Uh.
It is up to the patriotic and moderate people to defend themselves
to support farmers,
1 little red heart and.
Share with your friends!